everybody was freaking out about you
ever seen any of the trailers I think I
saw the first teaser where it's just
zooming out of the rock and like the
shark swims around okay well I saw the
second trailer that trailers go to crap
out of me
just like the very concept of I'm Greg
by the way I'm John well the shallows
the beginning here they have a new
trailer
normally when it's like for movies like
this I was already like a third trailer
I don't really care for them I heard
this trailer though is like a good new
marketing direction and in terms of like
keeping a long hot or not right about on
collateral let's just watch it it seems
like it's gonna be a clip or something I
don't know let's find out for a second I
thought they'd retitle it the shallows
the beginning and was about to throw the
throw
uh yeah I add up what's beautiful I'm
gonna go there
learning to be self-reliant takes time
and I work these other chef Ryan
Reynolds essentially I'll know where you
are going make your own she's gonna have
the cover a lot hard work become
self-reliant use a bit more than we have
you're not tough reliant you'll never do
any more than just yeah ah oh oh ah love
that when you're here
poor Blake oh bit
Wow well dose of self-reliance can do
wonders now you may think that's the end
of the story actually it's only the
beginning
Oh flies
that's an awesome tool it was that
speech I don't know I it sounded older
yeah didn't that's really cool I thought
I believe that was Nixon speaking oh you
definitely that's definitely Nixon and
in President Jimmy Carter but definitely
add to one of the two could have been
Bush notes okay yeah apparently spooby
has a theme huh that's suffering lights
and uh I think it's a little ironic yeah
it's like gravity like a rock not but it
is it's yeah jewelle is you know like
this woman stranded she's not that far
from her destination but you know sharks
are fast oh yeah I don't know if this is
an actual thing but you know like
location-based horror movies where it's
like oh it's all in a jungle it's all
like on a secluded beach like you know I
like that let's just cool that horror
they tend to take place in a in a very
specific amount of time yeah yeah like
it doesn't need it does usually spam a
lot like most four years yeah like it
usually takes plug like so that way you
know people get killed off and [ __ ] but
for I love horror like this you know
it's cool that Blake Lively is doing
this because she is Ryan Reynolds his
wife yeah and Ryan Reynolds did buried
which was a one-man show that's sure
this is like her little gem woman show
here yeah I was really juris surfing -
yeah it looks like no it looks like she
really threw herself into this movie and
and I hope this works just because of
that what this is looks cool to me
and I heard Ryan Reynolds is a acting
coach actually coach her for this - oh
cool okay that's a real fact people if
you can pull up just like a real like a
movie like this kind of has to thrive on
like a resourceful lead and just change
just tell ya one's attention if you
could deliver just like one of those
tension telephone movies like that would
be well they showed another trailer
where there's a couple of other dudes at
the ocean but you know like they're just
used to get killed off and way I'm sure
those show up is like oh hope so I'm
hoping this goes down a route that is
very clever not like repetitive or you
know I'm bored that's a problem with
stories like this I hope this is like a
salt like eighty to ninety minute film
yeah like lean but but like really sharp
like a really tight plot really you know
yeah cuz I like these kind
like phone booth and stuff yeah those
are cool kind of flicks it's awesome
because it gives you a chance to see
filmmakers working with something really
small and you usually get a damn good
lead performance at the same time you
get to see them become very creative in
a small environment and learn create
suspense and tension without like a
bunch of extra [ __ ] and what is there a
performance there are other kinds of
movies that you can basically kind of
make they'll work anyway because of the
formula or because of all the toys and
stuff around but this is a movie where
it's like if this is gonna be good like
you gotta be a competent director you
gotta be a tight writer and you got to
have a good compelling lead I'm excited
and I really hope this works because
this could be really cool
I heard that Blake Lively in order to
get fit for the role she had to become
bulimic that is the gossip of the girl
see what you did there because she's on
pretty little line and then got a lot
and they're all girls no I'm sorry
Salma Hayek oh that's right her in three
other teenagers hey Sony Pictures I'm
there I'm your guy I have money you know
I'm gonna do you know I'm gonna do I'm
gonna go to John's wallet oh that's fine
and I'm gonna you have no cash I know
give no cash no I use it your wallets
falling apart I know well this it's not
working I was gonna take out something -
yeah I was gonna throw it like a pimp
the show hey buddy can well I do but
it's all the way over there I'll go get
your cash
give me one second guys you want this oh
you made the tea shoes beautician you're
feeling joking real-time it's like Craig
Ferguson I'm so rich these days are you
are you rich yeah um hey what do you
think of Blake Lively I think Blake what
you're too
well guys if you like comedy subscribe
today everybody chiapas brightness
telethon $100 bills
John is Jerry reasons you got to find
out too Jerry
yeah blue mouse calm SS social media
manager Lizzie SS stand for go there and
find out blue house not calm people find
out what's going on follow us on
Facebook calm and Instagram and re I
mean blur and who knows maybe you get a
picture of John's nipple doom maybe
haven't seen your nipples in a very long
time John spent years it's a weird thing
to say to another probably don't go to
pool parties or the beach ever oh yeah
we don't yeah we don't do we that used
to be the [ __ ] well when we were young
when we were like second grader like I
remember we had really big nipples did I
really yeah yeah like big like penguin
nipples what does that mean what is look
like penguin nipples penguins do they
happen they do in my mind